it may look like a winter wonderland but
the once in a decade cold snap that
blasted Japan was far from pretty
sparking extreme weather warnings across
East Asia and bringing record low
temperatures icy conditions and snow
storms to the region causing travel
chaos in South Korea and Japan during
the busiest Lunar New Year period
it was quite a whiteout or it felt like
it suddenly turned twice so I guess the
driver couldn't see and crashed
the strong winds are believed to have
caused a cargo ship to sink between
Japan and South Korea's Jeju Island
Rescue workers search for crew members
in gusts that broke records in Northern
Japan
new snowfall and temperature records
were also set across the country and
just days earlier China recorded its
lowest ever temperature of minus 53
degrees Celsius in its northernmost City
but that didn't stop the cleanup
operations on the streets I swept about
6 to 700 meters of snow here starting
from noon my face may be frozen but my
body is warm
with another cold blast on the horizon
North Korea has issued an extreme cold
alert that's heightened concern for the
people in the poorest areas as
temperatures tumble caroleg Al Jazeera